during the World Series when I'm playing
the most important thing without
question that I have to focus on and
this is why I stopped focusing on
working on all this stuff is sleep if
I'm not rested I'm useless if I only get
five six hours and I have to go back the
next day and play 14 hours the chances
of me being at my best very very slim so
sleep is a priority what's the perfect
amount of sleep for you on those days
eight so eight hours is my go-to every
night during the World Series of Poker
it's just not possible because of the
way that it's structured sometimes the
tournaments end at 2 15 a.m I get home
about three o'clock
takes me 30 minutes 40 minutes to get to
sleep so let's say I'm in bed by four
well the tournament said you know two so
I have to get up and whatever so it's
very difficult to get exactly eight a
lot of the time you know and also get
back there in time is there any hacks to
uh quiet the mind
because you're going on a pretty intense
roller coaster mentally when you're
playing
is there any tricks to getting to sleep
given up I've been very lucky like I'm
blessed I don't know if it's because of
diet or what but I've always been a very
good sleeper you just shut off I get to
sleep and I sleep like a baby you know
and I also nap really well like during
the World Series sometimes what will
happen is let's say I get knocked out of
one event at 4 P.M and there's another
one that I can jump in instead of
jumping right into it I'll go into like
a private room and take 45 minute nap
and you know and give me enough energy
to to continue and sort of reset my mind
yeah and it solves a lot of problems
with the nap too it does yeah I feel
like the nap is is a magical trick in
life